[Applaudissements]
ils m'ont cyanure et non le bateau s'est
redressé cette fois taillé au les voiles
touche l'eau ils sont perdus
non non madame il se redresse une fois
plus même endroit tous les récits du rat
mort
ils vont virer de bord mis non plus si
si madame voilà qui est fait c'était
juste
ils ont dû passer à quatre mecs bâton
mais je conseil à madame de se rassurer
il se dirige vers le port maintenant
enfin oui madame
ce monsieur eric tabarly c'est un bon
gamin
probablement le meilleur du monde sauf à
douze et dix fois de pin
il ya certainement eu des imprudences
commises c'est miracle qu'il n'ait pas
des bras tu es viré tout le vent force 7
sur l'échelle de beaufort comment
expliquez-vous que monsieur tabary et
pris un risque pareil madame je ne me
cherche pas d'explication
oui vous êtes le meilleur des serviteurs
vous pouvez vous exprimer librement
je suis sûr que nous pensons la même
chose pour marie a pris la barre des
mains de monsieur tabac qu'on dit c'est
possible
il a voulu lui montrer comment on
faisait
c'est à craindre madame c'est tout lui
mais monsieur a une énorme personnalité
ma damas au bout d'une heure avec minoui
il trouverait le moyen de lui apprendre
le violon
bonjour l'échangeur moiselle bonjour à
des embauches à noisy
vous paraissez perturbé non non non
juste un peu ce cui madame le chauffeur
est une prendre la gare avec la maserati
cousine points à 3 cents là oui madame
nous attendons le mécanicien qui vient
d'angleterre par avion taxi pourquoi le
champion ne connaît pas la cadillac andy
va chercher du monde à la glace je pris
ces dames d'excusés gilbert la maserati
ne sort jamais il aura voulu lui faire
prendre l'air voulez-vous faire et la
fenêtre
oui aller se vendre
je vais vous servir le thé madame hall
entier mademoiselle ou départ cette idée
de vouloir remporter la coupe america 6
très bien l'entraîneur veut c'est très
dur oui ce voilier doit coûter à peu
près autant qu'un portable bon aloi
tout réussit à monsieur l'argent le gars
ici mais depuis quelques temps ils
veulent restes humains larrousset hommes
et là nous aurons du mal ruban ça n'a
pas des façons enfin les tarines la
rosette ne veut même pas entendre les
dix ans réglementaire et tout ce que je
demande c'est qu'ils n'essaient pas
d'acheter la légion donne ma rose est
non l'imam de 11
le thé madame merci à tous de thé
mademoiselle sud non je vous remercie
beaucoup madame et monsieur becks ne va
pas tarder à arriver le week-end risque
d'être laborieuse je m'installais si
vous le permettez tout est prêt pour la
moselle sudre bien sûr madame
l'appartement anne de bretagne attend
mademoiselle comme d'habitue merci oui
mademoiselle va trouver la température
de son appartement à 18° hygrométrie à
34 % d'humidité merci il va vous servir
les monsieur tient à ce qu'on utilise
les reconditionner mademoiselle alors
vous trouvez mon avis en bonne santé en
ce moment lui excellente madame
cependant il entreprend tant de choses
on vous a prévenu que le général de
ville en vert ne venait pas dîner ce
soir
oui madame nous avons du mal à trouver
des invités qu'on vous l'a au madame
nous avons eu des artistes un champion
cycliste de l'année membres du
gouvernement jamais personne d'officiel
ils viendront madame nous progressons
grâce à vous oui oh merci madame
il ya longtemps je suis tenté de vous
dire une bêtise louis madame ne devrait
pas s'en priver davantage au fond nous
avons le même destin vous et moi j'étais
arraché d'une famille de magistrats part
à l'uci avec de 20 ans qui voulait tout
croquer vous avez qui arrachent et du
service d'une famille ducale pas réussi
avec de 40 ans qui voulait toujours tout
croquer je suis très honoré du
rapprochement madame puis je me
permettre à mon tour de vous faire
observer que monsieur a toujours voulu
ce qui se fait de mieux
merci ça m'aidera d'y penser j'en aurai
parfois besoin
nous avons de durs moments vous et moi
il y en a de plus malheureux que nous
m
c'est du thé pour des maramures atassi
de tomates au mille sabords est d'abord
en du bassin vous comprenez tabarly
pourquoi at on tant de mal à gagner la
coupe america c'est parce que tout le
monde veut naviguer comme le voisin
hoebeke ce jeudi il faut naviguer tout
travers pour décontenancer l'adversaire
alors jetés à la rue par monsieur tabary
est parti vous définitivement
il a pris sa voiture et il est rentré
chez lui avec moche et non pas par le
voilà mais il fallait le râteau ni
fenêtres condamnées pour des petits
commercial jeunes à lui firent mal momo
qui sera le plus grand tu seras le plus
fort c'est mon fils tabarly déchire mon
chèque ils pouvaient se payer 3 pen
duick avec ça donc c'est un imbécile
tant mieux ça va je n'ai pas besoin de
lui je viens de prouver up est il dans
les copains m'avaient vu manoeuvrer me
lucien bien dangereuse
je fais tout dangereusement d'où les
autres ont peur
moi pas c'est pourquoi je suis ce que je
suis tudor précieux dans son appartement
monsieur ici j'avais ici tout de suite
dernier fut de savoir qu'est ce que nous
avons à dîner ce soir
en général nous n'avons plus il s'est
décommandé smact de te faire [ __ ] à la
retraite celui là ça va pas tarder
maintenant c'est dessus traité en
communication avec l'extérieur à l'été
quel est votre homme est ce que je me
jamaï coupes illégales à aller à peine
moins un coup de rasoir au galop à l'est
des pays-bas savoir des billets est
aussi bavard maman agir j'ai trop bas
l'autre en général pour ce soir des
envies de généraux moi en ce moment
alors si on se trompe on vient d'appeler
du ministère des affaires étrangères
monsieur par les militants non monsieur
monsieur simon jonnier directeur des
affaires africaines
il m'a demandé s'il pouvait passer ici
vers 11 heures du matin
oui dans un quart d'heure sa taupe ah
bah oui j'ai voulu vous le passez pas ce
monsieur m'a dit sa mission auprès de
vous et est confidentiel et qu'il
n'était pas question de vous entretenir
par téléphone du 8 juin les affaires ces
tranches j'ai voulu vous consulté mais
ce monsieur m'a dit qu'il parle à sa
détresse et bien qu'ils passent j'ai du
monde à voir dans tous les ministères
sauf aux affaires c'est trop cher et
hermétique tous au quai d'orsay
mon genre ne voit pas plus heureux et
voilà qui rendre une petite visite à
davies sûrs
c'est bon ça mais c'est bon c'est bon
allez mon gros tiers dessus il doit vous
n'avez jamais dépiauter un latin way et
judas des staffs de bepa vocales sont à
fleur je vous dis ça à la maison jean
millet janvier samedi quelque chose à
jausiers titan au jury oui l'autre jour
au bar du pillon un vieux schnock en
jaquette avec rosette sur canapé va
faire à verser la moitié de montbartier
avec son coude sur mon veston à fin de
race mauvaise santé
mais pour les bannières par l'oim il
s'est excusé comme s'il m'avait crever
un oeil tout en parlant avec les
pincettes de rosette à rugby alain
lozeau evry le présenter à notre zoo se
sont excellents à celle ci aux jeunes y
est consigné du gouvernement comme elle
a dit ça aux affaires africaines à se
marrer quand ils me reconnaître vous ne
vous êtes pas ma mère m'a pas laissé le
temps le voyou bien le gardien de genève
bon à savoir la boue sur la situation en
mauritanie jean-pierre dans ce coin là
avec laurent pourra portuaire c'est vrai
ils n'arrêtent pas de monter une valeur
qui n'arrête pas de monter connais pas
bon ont fait naître la fille 5 ouvert le
1er janvier jonnier outre les schistes
on en parlait chez monsieur le duc de
brissac une des lumières du quai d'orsay
est bien de rendre une visite votre
lumière un da premiers pas à saint lô
renault en effet monsieur quels
vêtements doivent prêter à aucune raison
de m'en dimanche et un pantalon blanc
blazer avec 810 d'oak park vous
vérifierez si le ruban au gibier le
ruban sur un blazer monsieur et alors ça
ne se fait jamais j'inaugure
monsieur m'a bien dit qu'il désirait
garder les patrons
ah ben là j'aurais l'air donne l'idée
mais c'est la raison il offre aussi peu
tes dents lui j'y pense ça vous
ennuierait de ses puces et les vôtres je
ne sais pas mais moi ça me ferait
plaisir pensé laisser les puces et nous
allons gilles parent par colette je vais
y penser voilà on peut travailler en
silence et laisser sudre fermeture alors
son travail
les amis de paul jorion vous demande une
cotisation pour son épée d'académicien
le danger le poil à lui payer tout seul
non parce que pal usage monsieur 2001 en
question s'est passé beaucoup trop faut
ça pour qu'on le remarque partout dans
le monde sur le vitalisme ans l'auteur
notaire vous appelle un cosmonaute de la
finance et je lis que ceux de re2
signature midas
ça veut dire quoi sabina devoir aller
demander sur l'adresse au monde
envoyez une caisse de mort aux 6 67 et
en coffret de laval avec quatre ans huit
jours de france prépare un numéro sur
les belles demeures ils demandent s'ils
peuvent envoyer des photos grâce à votre
chaton chatou lequel j'en ai 3 à celui
ci monsieur mercredi robin bhar d'accord
mais vous surveillerez bel objet
précieux vous autres un séjour d'un
liste c'est tellement faux chilienne
allez vas-y déplaire il faudra mettra un
amoureux monsieur marquardt qui vient
d'être nommé officier de la légion
d'honneur
oui oui oui
aj je rage une endroit qu'elle connaît
rien des patients du oui
fola qui n'a marqué qu'à l'arrivée je
suis rapide julie mettre un bout bien de
tous la rose est mort et apparemment ça
va bien ça va dire sa manière c'est pas
l'arrêter à tia koné 300 put d'emprunt
sncf à ses clients un wright a en fait
un désert à ses clients c'est comme s'il
est classée en zone sinistrée
la rosette et paris arrivant le préfet y
mange ça ne regarde c'est une pluie qui
tombait fort tenu les terrains de
beaulieu s'est pas de ça qu'il est mort
non yadir mort qui tue si c'était vrai
il aurait pu apprécier vivant laisse
tomber
nous avons invité à déjeuner et ça c'est
pas 4 up est bien éteint de la ferme
africaine au quai d'orsay
ma pauvre et gdf tout je ne connais pas
sur ça fume 5 1 du mois saviez pas que
tu as fait oui monsieur
ils s'étaient rencontrés d'urgence
confidentiellement pourtant les siennes
je ne fais pas de politique je fais de
l'argent ça communique tu veux mais tu
atteindras que tu la boucle qu'est ce
que vous aimez pas la musique
ensuite je gagne et on puise des jeunes
avec nous mis à part quelques phrases au
long des 1 pour les si on attend qu'il
est passé par heart my father dit et par
mots sortis chèque de sotchi solaire
c'est beau hein m'agresse klaxons des
bovins
quel argenterie olympique l'appui tout
passé au verbe les scènes à l'argent ces
hauts fonctionnaires peuvent être m ça
les rend amer je vais la cuisine tu ne
sais pas si ce monsieur est aux riches
mais tu peux lui faire faire un
diplomate
comment 3 mais ça fait la muse et non
sur un peu dans l'exécution que cotto
galicien que tu vas pas ma poupée
convient lucien et parfois je sors comme
un écolo entre les coudes face à dany
goût entre les quotas légaux alors où
elle est folle où elle a une envie de
cible d'un tel succès la cravate qu'il
faut ça à obligatoire messieurs la
cravate club avec le blazer avec le 2è
pas mis long ruban
non non non messieurs en soit c'est une
faute de 20,1 dignité a indiqué ce
serait un suicide est parfait oui vous
êtes pas fait c'est ma raison d'être
monsieur se doit être l'invité de
monsieur pas vous laisser entrer
personne d'autre diam sur sucre
qu'est-ce que quelques escales annonce
ci dessus
qu'est ce qu'un amoureuse en vrai
monsieur plus beaux draps au jour bon je
n'ai pas vécu à bien monsieur fait vous
servir quelque chose dont un appartenant
au groupe est à carburer ce guignol vous
apporte-t-elle travail bien monsieur oui
lui en effet est à temps quatre minutes
dans l'eau le candidat denis hamel de la
croix nous citerons on trouve présent
beauté merci monsieur copé
né dans la nuit
oui n'avez jamais eu envie tout à perdre
ce serait trop dessus de la condition
même si yann et moi je ne veux pas c'est
timide prise en fleurs il a un casting
comme dire une idée noire avec chauffeur
et cocardes vous faites des jeunes et le
chauffeur bien fait mais ce monsieur
n'est pas seul un homme femme
ecclésiastique monsieur oui un peu des
deux quoi ecclésiastique vêtus de blanc
le parc le temps c'est l'autre nom non
monsieur non un père démission je crois
bien
ah ça y est je suis pas inquiet pour une
quête est pas mon dieu et bien vous
laisser tout rennais bon on m'a déjà
appelé monsieur l'ambassadeur
j'ai pour un poste mais il est en titre
ambassadeur de france à vie il n'y en a
que cinq ou six et ce titre passe avant
tout les zones non oui on nous dit pas à
monsieur le ministre à louis joxe bien
qu'il est été plusieurs fois mais
monsieur l'ambassadeur
nous sommes peu nombreux à connaître la
nuance monsieur monsieur l'ambassadeur
au début de la conversation monsieur
après ne sera pas ça dort au début de la
conversation monsieur après et le curton
mon révérend père au début mon père
après une réunion à faire au début mon
père après beau pour être vrai dans une
bonne minute et bien
1 2 3 4
un anticyclone nous fallut des açores
mon père ce héros au sourire si doux
suivi d'intel eu mon père ce héros au
sourire si doux suivi d'un suivi d'un
doigt par un anticyclone devenus des
açores mon père ce héros au sourire si
doux suivi d'un thé lui même il ne s'est
pas non plus
[Musique]
monsieur l'ambassadeur simon joumier le
révérend père toi
si je ne m'abuse parce que j'ai déjà eu
l'honneur d'entrer en contact avec vous
du moindre mon coude avec le mot c'est
exact monsieur l'ambassadeur je suis un
pardonne c'est moi qui suis flatté pour
métier que j'espère que mes excuses ont
été assez construit pour n'avoir pas à
les renouveler la maladresse je venais
de ma part monsieur non monsieur
monsieur monsieur plus permettez moi de
vous présenter le révérend père tout
rare de la congrégation du désert de nos
plus précieux auxiliaires dans les bons
rapports que le gouvernement s'est
fortement clear au coeur du continent
noir avec les nouveaux dirigeants de
notre ancien as adoré mon révérend père
la cgem a pris messieurs s'il vous plaît
traces et il fait sa main at on fait ça
genève
on avait beaucoup vanté la splendeur du
château de courcelles je n'en reste pas
mois comment vivre elle est maire apache
est un des châteaux des yeux bleus
conquérant un format nouveau par al
magnifique ambassade une ambassade en
normandie caen s'est passé jusque vers
la normandie comme attaché à la france
depuis 12 104 elle ne serait pas d'une
grande utilité tous en 4l
ça fait un bail du groupe dont le plus
gros en rentrant quelle merveille
ça c'est une de ses toiles de son époque
bleus
à
mais tout l'avant de mieux comme chant
piano magnum les 80 hommes tête de cuvée
1937 de la potel virbac et nous on n'en
connaît que trois autres en angleterre
chez le duc de norfolk chez l'éditeur
japonais
enfin vous fatiguez pas les écoute pas
c'est pas la peine mais paris - au
freezer cinq minutes et vous me
l'apporter dans le sauternais une tête
de kuyt et 1937 au freezer monsieur
demande un crime mac attachant pas
exactement de la frappe et monsieur mais
pas mort à la tour d'autriche en jeu
servait dans la neige
ben c'est pas la saison où ça freine
l'adorent et bien d'autres cultures
qu'on vous mon vieux il est temps d'en
venir à la mission ministre ma config
auprès de la liste des missions mission
confidentielle
j'espère que beaucoup moins le plaisir
de déjeuner avec nous dès la tombée à
monsieur consacré que peu de sens car je
veux rejoindre en plus dont l'invité du
gouvernement le colonel sambo présidence
de la république du talent de quartier
je vous suppose au courant de sa visite
des biens descendant les champs visuel
et un petit drapeau
encore un qui gueule ou piquer du fric
la visite du colonel sont beaux et d'une
plus vaste portée je n'ai certes pas de
président des états unis la reine
d'angleterre
mais notre gouvernement est très loin
très loin de prendre sa visite à la
légère n'est ce pas on paye leur est
grand tort je me serais fait une joie de
partager votre repas mais je dois proton
rejoindre deauville où le président
souhaitent déjeuner au bord de la mer et
visiter la plage célèbre jeu le
ramènerait en fin d'après midi
et là monsieur bex est l'objet de la
mission qui me vaut d'être ici de toute
ma carrière monsieur l'ex je ne crois
pas avoir jamais affronté tâche plus
délicate n'est-il pas vrai mon père
il ne met pas plus agréable d'aidé à son
succès j'espère que nous sommes trois
ici à faire passer le bien de notre pays
avant nous convenance le compte y sera
quand j'aurais compris j'y viens le
chemin a auparavant je dois vous
préciser que ma mission auprès de voûte
est strictement officieuse si capital
qu'elle soit serait catégoriquement
désavoué par le pouvoir qui elle venait
à ses ventes et une torche à monsieur je
suis une tombe
en plus qu'est mais une temps vous êtes
aussi un homme d'affaires de premier
plan et on s'est surtout depuis la
sphère du watergate que des hommes de
votre envergure sont capables d'assurer
à leur entretien
l'hospitalité de bandes magnétiques
pouvez vous affirmer qu'il n'existe dans
cette pièce aucune installation
permettant d'enregistrer secrètement les
propos qui s'y tiennent
je vous en donne devant témoins ma
parole d'honneur
c'est une valeur sûre mais il ya aussi
les portes
permettez vous au révérend de s'assurer
qu'elles n'ont pas d'oreilles la tchèque
où mon père merci monsieur baisse des
cigares merci un quai d'orsay a à cette
circonstance et non en effet je ne fume
pas mais moi je fus merci s'il vous
plaît pas
bon alors je peux aller droit au but le
ministre a fait avant mais hier dans la
journée sur une demeure de grandes à lui
sur la côte normande et chez un
particulier de grande forme
je vous dois cet hommage que votre
château et vous-même répondait c'est oui
mon père est oui dans la vie il ya des
hauts et des bas ça c'est un bac et sur
you
ne fais plus bien je continue si vous le
permettez bien fait
on souhaite en très haut lieu précisé de
vous même qu'on retourne à deauville
je suggère à notre hôte d'honorer votre
château de sa visite plutôt que de
passer une soirée l'a16 fida l'unesco
est il est blanc noir entre les deux os
ils tirent sur l'anthracite mais il est
relativement francophone pourquoi
voulez-vous le large et chez moi en tous
votre colonel votre consentement
préalable faciliterait cette confidence
je pourrais franchise si c'est pour le
faire ratatiner par des belphégor comme
un vulgaire lumumba j'ai rien contre
l'idée mais j'ai beau temps que ça
déroulé de monsieur belge je suis les
affaires étrangères pas l'intérieur
pardo un moment d'humour le hasard une
première entrevue de doit pas vous faire
oublier que ce n'est pas comme on compte
que je me trouve ici et bastien quand
même quelque chose en droit du rallye un
bien apprenez tout d'abord que le
président sambo est le maître absolu de
son plein et quand ça l'état de galanga
géographiquement anodin n'en recèle pas
moins comment dirais-je mende une
particularité dont la france doit
s'assurer la disposition et plus encore
empêcher toute autre puissance d'en
tirer parti
on compte sur moi pour canaliser le
cocktail maintenant oui car le temps
dont nous disposons et étroitement
limiter le président sambourg part pour
londres demain et pour washington dans
huit jours
de là il se rendra à l'onu pour y
rencontrer les chefs des délégations
étrangères et pour entendre ce qu'ils
offrent
nous ne pouvons pas donné ces quitté la
france pour cette quête aux enchères où
nous serions distance et il doit avoir
conclu avec nous et je perds mon exposé
la situation mon père merci le père
touran maintien dans la capitale un
dispensaire que nous subventionne il ne
faut pas vous laisser abuser par le
terme capital monsieur ben gaudin ghosn
est elle à ce qu'un pitoyable bidonville
de pagaille dans la jungle
hormis les quelques bungalows des corps
consulaires et bien entendu le palais
président
ciel la caserne de la garde et le parc
automobile de la présidence il ya tout
de même des routes
oui une auto de 3 km pour gagner le
bassin où est amarré le yacht du
président et une bretelle pour mener aux
arènes ce qui pêche a pas encore ça se
doit faire maintenant mais nous y
arriverons oui poser votre bateau nous
servir et moi-même membros et 67 au père
collection fbi il y a trois mois un
trouble de géologues allemand a obtenu
du président sans l'autorisation de
prospecter dans le sud du pays sous
bonne garde bien entendu et s'ouvre aux
baisses de rapporter aux précédents
exclusivement le résultat de leurs
recherches
après quelques jours de prospection ils
se sont présentés au palais mais le même
soir où les at on retrouvé mon père
le même soir les a retrouvés morts ou
mourants dans un bras du fleuve infestée
de crocodiles mois
il avait découvert quelque chose oui
c'est pour ça qu'il aurait et arriver
des bricoles
pourquoi se poser la question d'un tueur
colonel temps pour la vérité monsieur
bête est entre les mains de dieu voire
se vexe un particulier et adler un chef
d'état a des obligations pénible mais
celui-ci vous me demandez de marseille
paralysées
mais comme le président de la république
et le président républicain des gardes
moi pas vous pouvez encore refusé
machinex les couverts aux gens
localement là vous avez la providence a
voulu que je revienne leurs villages
dans ma pirogue au moment où un de ces
malheureux vivait encore et il a pu me
confier qu'ils avaient remis un rapport
établissant avec certitude l'existence
d'un champ pétrolifère
oui de plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres
du pétrole remontent de dieu
sans pardon mon père
alors ça je vous fais toutes mes excuses
je les ferai parvenir mais du pétrole
monsieur est actuellement l'élément
fondamental de la stratégie
internationale aussi la possession des
gisements du tonga signifierait ton
notre pays l'indépendance absolue et et
la suprématie dans bien des domaines
mais grâce à la confidence du mourant
j'ai pu alerter à temps notre
gouvernement est pour l'instant nous
sommes seuls sur les rangs pour
l'exploitation du gisement la
personnalité du colonel s'en vont vous
inquiètent-elles toujours autant cher
monsieur je me fais pour doucement mais
je me fais aimeriez-vous participé à
cette opération
alors là je lui fais toute affaire mais
pourquoi portez-vous cette gâterie à moi
eux n'avaient peut être pas renta
d'amiraux monsieur l'exploitation des
gisements pétrolifères
ils ne relèvent ni de mon ministère ni
de mon contexte famille à vous allez
comprendre comment nous nous trouvons là
tout s'est enchaîné très vite depuis
hier le président veut voir un château
l'euro très chouettes votre nom
traversent les routes ce père du
gouvernement comme comme un frein d'une
bière vos capacités sentiments voilà ça
c'est vrai je connais pas l'unique notre
homme car diverses ne veut rien signé le
cauchemar
notre seule notre dernier mais notre
meilleure chance notre salon ou pas
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire exactement et
bien faire signer ce traité de cession
que j'espère laisser sur votre bureau en
prenant congé elle serait mon intérêt et
bien avant le gouvernement s'en
remettraient sous contrôle à votre
initiative pour l'exploitation des
gisements concernés
votre rétribution sur minimes en
apparence mais proportionnel au
rendement est basé sur la cotation
moyenne du marché international les
conditions même accordé à cecil rhodes
pour la couronne d'angleterre en 1897
pour les gisements aurifères du
transvaal cinq ans plus tard cécile rode
mouret milliards mais moi je m'engageais
à mourir dans les cinq ans restons
sérieux monsieur bex je n'ai pas terminé
il est également apparu au ministre
qu'au cas où vous réussirez à faire
signer ce traité au colonel sabow ce au
service rendu à la nation justifierait
votre élévation par décret spécial au
grade d'officier de la légion d'honneur
ma mission est officieuse mais vous
pouvez tenir cet engagement pour
officiel votre réponse monsieur bex la
seule permise 1 france dessus la nation
m'appelle je réponds présent c'est le
même que j'attende y est alors je vais à
présent vous exposer la marche à suivre
conçu par nos services secrets pour un
résultat rapide enlevé avant demain la
visite officielle du président sambi a
pris fin ce matin à l'elysée donc la
voie et elle nous mais nous ne vous ai
pas retouché d'organes aux services
secrets ont conçu un plan que nous
considérons comme seule efficace nous
serons discret à vous de la grosse île
mais il va vous falloir de l'audace
obtint du pétrole je sifflerai cas
suspects les quatre faiblesses de notre
homme sont sa cupidité délirant que ce
traité devrait satisfaire sa gourmandise
extra l'adorent sa vanité himalayenne et
ça lubricité en forme de record du monde
et j'ai quelques heures ont satisfait
les timides penchant de 7 ans je loue
équatoriale je vous laisse avec le
perturbant kivu documentera sur les 3
premiers parlementaires cupidité il vous
est plus chaud à traiter vanité il vous
décortiquera le personnage et
gourmandise
il vous expliquera l' usage d'une
bourriche de potel et chabot que mon
chauffeur va remettre à l'office et
d'après lubricité j'espère que j'aurai
pas m'en charger une jeune personne est
en route pour votre château monsieur pex
la mairie si elle à s'envoyer en l'air
avec le président sous mon toit
vous pouvez encore refusé elle sera demi
tour ces cours ans
ouais
c'est que la suite mais permettez moi là
je vous dis que cette personne a des
manières de rennes qu'elle relève
directement de nos services spéciaux qui
l'ont sélectionné à un situe le colonel
dans un état d'euphorie favorable à
notre objectif ce n'est en aucun cas une
prostituée est une spécialiste vous me
rassurer
didot rhône et alapage au quai d'orsay
la page tout le livre demeure et
l'histoire de france quand il a bien
inventé c'est comme dans les affaires
chez la souris qui piège de la msa
monsieur si le faire déjeuner le colonel
semblant monde il est grand temps que je
le rejoigne le traité et en triple
exemplaire d'étudier le attentivement
avant mon retour
qu'est ce que c'est un disque c'est un
disque dont vous comprendrez facilement
usage seller me dicte à nantes alors
qu'il faut ligne du talent en gare et à
distance
messieurs je vais tout mettre en oeuvre
pour l'un et l'autre invité le plus vite
possible
time is money pays raccompagne religieux
sista sa voiture bien monsieur si
monsieur je viens de suivre
quelle superbe demain on aimerait tout
emporté
un repère il doit pas tombé beaucoup de
neige sur votre dispose elle
remplacerait avantageusement les
moustiques et les fourmis rouges sur
monsieur l'avenir pas mois à la grandeur
de votre page pour avoir un fort tu
d'être libre pense que a piqué de toutes
les infortunes cher monsieur dit qu'est
ce que c'est que cette tourista que son
chauffeur aurait déposé avant de vous le
dire
cher monsieur que je ne puis à regret
après mon fils je voudrais dissiper
quelques fausses vu que pourrait vous
inspirer une conception tout laïque de
mon caractère sacré je suis prêtre
monsieur et jabot mines le péché métal
également le président sans vos n'ayant
pas reçu le baptême n'est imputable aux
yeux de l'église que du péché originel
n'est ce pas hé bé but les aberrations
de sa nature les dérèglements de sa
conduite ma fille je certes mais sans
m'indigner et ce n'est pas pour moi
démérité que de les mettre à profit pour
le bien de la patrie où le seigneur a
jugé utile de me faire net
voilà vous m'avez compris tu autres à
mieux me prendra bien je ne suis pas
dans les affaires seront sans connaître
à un push sur les restrictions matin
non c'est la bourriche tout ce qu'on
prend la main et bien sûr monsieur 7
goristes contient haineux une venaison
dont le président sans vos est friand de
père en fils si je puis dire une
venaison quasi impossible à se procurer
à paris et d'ailleurs le protocole
répudie sur les tables officiel il n'y a
cependant aucun mais qu'ils puissent
réduire davantage le président sambi et
donner ainsi un caractère de chaudes
cordialité aux repas que vous nous
offrez ce soir est raccord c'est quoi
cette part pas qu un salon à ses voisins
du sein
mais en plus évoluées allez salut au
bout de votre pensée ce sera la réponse
omnia caron pour lui c'est un des buzz
tout seraient même poussière vous voulez
que je fasse pour fille de la saison du
met lass maurico à ce monsieur bien des
francophones se ressentent encore d'une
ascendance franco fava
non ce serait pour le président son beau
le couronnement fassent tuer et inespéré
de sa visite en france il y ait plus
je comprends pas les recul et analyser
et même à l'hôtel de ville
dites moi c'est le volet seront là comme
vous dites vous l'avez trouvé où par
walt je suppose
les services spéciaux sont rarement
embarrassé un appariteur de l'hôtel dieu
a été approché 120 confidences j'ajoute
que la bourriche sera remise à votre
cuisinière comme pièces de gibier est
attendue même dans mon frigo
oui mais moins qu'à la morgue un
établissement respectable pour que cette
fois votre faim mort sont là c'est
quelque chose de reconnaissable en
entier oui non mais rassurez vous il est
déjà parent et émincé et vous voulez que
ma femme et moi nous nous nous regardons
le président se farcir son petit plein
entre l'atabal milanaise et les asper
sauce gribiche je crachais veut ce que
vous n'ayez pas saisi toute la pensée de
monsieur le conseiller du gouvernement
non le président sambi serait sans nul
doute profondément offensé mêmes
irréparablement heurté si madame votre
épouse et vous-même hésitiez à partager
son plaisir
mais cela créerait un déplorable climat
de désapprobation qui annulerait
l'efficacité certaine de votre attention
vous voulez que ma femme et moi mini tap
to do so nanan songé seulement à la
grandeur à 10 cibles du résultat dépasse
tout mon père dans des parcs aux jo et
aussi aux immenses avantages que vous en
tirerez
quand même trempe m depuis ce matin
votre épouse ainsi qu'aux gens ignorants
de qualité il retourne
l'étiquette potel et chabot figure sur
la bo riche que monsieur si vos geôliers
vous a apporté à titre amical mais c'est
pas ça sur la bourriche qui m'inquiète
un stand-up
non mais je comprends vos scrupules non
non c'est pas de question ne serait plus
une question d'estomac
on va là dans ces conditions il me
paraît inutile ce à quoi bon faire une
seconde sa vérité même réflexion que
t'es trop quand même dur à avaler nous
d'être là c'est indispensable n'a pas
mené tout au tout non mais je suggère
cuissot de venaison à la pta noguez sur
le menu wii comme ça ça passera ou non
mais le président et fin connaisseur il
ne se trompera pas au fumet et la partie
sera superbement tanguay 1 j'espère que
le directeur des affaires africaines et
vous-même serait de la fête on va se
régaler la question ne se pose pas pour
moins cher monsieur
bon pourquoi pas nous nous sommes
vendredi le président sambi est
accoutumé à me voir respecter encore
l'ancien commandement lorsque je suis
son hôte
bonjour je tromperait mavin reprenant
des aspects ma part d'abnégation sera de
dire quand même le bénédicité au me le
permettez nous de partout vers les
superbes années de votre part et nous
appeler mon père je vous recommande et
c'est la plus belle collection de tunis
après celle du chacun des plans a et
qu'elles puissent ils n'en sont pas peu
fiers c'est la reproduction exacte de la
pièce toc tu as barak et bien à propos
de vanité puisque vous me faites penser
les noirs sont de grands enfants tous
ceux qui briguent les fascine lors les
bijoux les diamants les attendrissent ne
le souhaitez pas à la tentation débats
vont perdre ce soir pour le dîner le
noir quand il va reconnaître son quatre
heures il va pas en faire un plat
zur non mais rassurez vous ce n'est pas
un homme a commenté les honneurs qui lui
sont dus
le ciel du mât voiles v familière home -
voudriez vous de prendre un peu
d'exercice avant le dîner vous voulez
que je fasse elle un châle ou grandier
nos tombes et j'aperçois les ruines
d'une chapelle au bout de l'allée la
foulée la rebâtir vous préviens a déjà
fait le coup de la cathédrale non
seulement remuer un peu de terre 5 ou 6
fait le terreau plus cadre du dénommé
creusée à peine par si ça vous amuse
ce n'est pas le mot mais je pensais au
repas de ce soir il serait charitable
d'assurer à ce qui restera de la pièce
de résistance une sépulture chrétienne
j'avais oublié ce détail
c'est une règle impérieuse de notre
ordre rendre les derniers devoirs autre
est passé si peu qu'il en subsiste veux
pas me refuser ça creuse et mon père
creuse et je vous remercie pour le
défunt homme un cannibale cocu et
gardien de cimetière h dans les schémas
rose est annoncée sur poney
l'encyclopédie universelle et britt a du
talent et s'est préparée - topo sur le
pétrole et ses dérivés
il faut savoir quelque chose assez drôle
j'ai pu faire du tout
la collaboratrice de monsieur
l'ambassadeur demande est reçu 700 tr la
collabos croyant louis bien entendu mais
des raisons c'est la bonne carte d'idron
les vendredis aujourd'hui oui monsieur
dans sa partie lancée mais qu'on ne
vendredi à l'église distance le voyageur
monsieur et de plus est venu facultatif
pour les tire-au-flanc peut-être pas
pour un professionnel
ce soir ne repasse pas les plats jamais
dans un grand dîner monsieur à bord est
encore une belle somme
bonjour mademoiselle à beauzelle du
matin c'est mademoiselle mais sans
impatience
nora dior comme le viaduc je connais
très bien duc n'avait rien à négocier
mais ce monsieur bex lui-même enchanté
bon et bien voilà je viens travailler
nous n'attendions vraiment b&you
toujours condescendant déjà content
j'avais deux fois tout de suite
inutile de vous égarer dans des pensées
folâtre ce serait peine perdue pour vous
et du temps gâché pour tout le monde je
suis ici pour vous connaître et pour
connaître cette maison ça change tout
mettons 7,2 mais on ne dit pas vous en
connaissez vous en visite et de paraît
tous les jours
il est arrivé d'en fréquenter deux cyber
athlètes les services de réserve pour la
vo le gratin vous me prenez pour une
call girl
je vous accorde le bénéfice du tout
leur pari merci alors pour dissiper tout
malentendu
je ne suis pas manipulée par les
services je fais partie des certes je
suis ce que les russes appellent une
hirondelle gaz ou du bois quelques
éclaircissements un fonctionnaire comme
elle qui travaille pour le gouvernement
un oeil sur laurier le set j'ai envie de
la patrie en somme ça se pratique depuis
la vie non vous connaissez dalila dalida
des questions restent en france 1
c'est une hirondelle et salomé qui s'est
offert la tête de saint jean baptiste
c'est encore une hirondelle un
rassemblement volo tort seulement depuis
la technique s'est améliorée j'ai dû
faire un stage de deux ans à l'école du
sexe mardi à l'école de sexe tout ça
avec un oeil en urss
j'ai obtenu mon diplôme avec la
meilleure des mentions sont interdites
aux moins de 18 ans
je peux obtenir n'importe quoi de
n'importe quel homme
n'importe où même dans un ascenseur de
grands magasins un jour de soldes
il est en quelque sorte une rondelle sur
ordinateur c'est à fait ça une
hirondelle programme est aussi efficace
qu'un saut m'a raté va marquer de
chapeau on met pas souvent là vous avez
ressenti fierté croyez le bien
l'éducation sexuelle au niveau de la
création
elle y penser après tout la même si le
jambon exister en france que tu te fable
[ __ ] c'est notre spécialité
non nous n'en avons pas encore
naturellement toujours en retard d'une
guerre
pas mal occupé mois de l'épreuve
française du sexe a pas de petites
histoires du maccabi délais je vous
engage comme directrice à
désappointement à faire pâlir envie à
l'ambassade
oui qu'on perd pas son temps à bavarder
avec moi naturellement pour sa voix que
je vous revois ta vie tu pour vous
racontiez les petits d'état vous fait
les demandes et les réponses quand je
suis lancé je parle pour deux repris une
jolie dot ont quitté les services mais
je trouve le moyen de vous y laissez en
vous évitant de grimper à la sauce eux
c'est otis amour c'est donc une
quelconque horizontale peut-être pas
pouvoir
et puis vous oubliez que je suis sous
contrat avec les services c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas pour habitude de badiner le
double jeu c'est la base de tout
espionnage bien conçu ça on ne vous
décourage pas facilement messieurs paix
on ne résiste pas à theix quand vous
prenez ma bonne volonté vous accorde une
petite avance pour vous offrir une
nouvelle panoplie non pas à garder sa
balle langage des fleurs des sur des
bons vieux rêve à lancer franc ça fait
quand même 10 briques pouvons nous en
terminer avec les détails de ma mission
les détails j'ai horreur des d'état
j'ai des instructions trappistes ce cas
je n'ai pas après comme chez vous je
suis chez moi alors je suis chez moi
puisque je suis votre femme femme un
homme comme vous a certainement les
moyens d'avoir une femme légitime tels
que moi à ce point là voire quatre si je
voulais eh bien je serai votre épouse
quand rassurez-vous momentanée et
provisoire d'hommes les services en ont
ainsi décidé d'avoir servi sur bâle
grâce ayez je suis les gens à poser
aujourd'hui des bouges attend béton très
costaud mater et bien dans ces
conditions je laisse à votre femme la
place qui lui revient
j'espère bien potable et dans le lit du
colonel sambo
avant parce que la colonnade
expressément à coucher avec toutes les
femmes de ses hôtes du trésor du louvre
aussi cette manie était devenu un
protocole le colonel va pouvoir se
vanter de retour dans son pays d'avoir
fait crac boum avec la femme du premier
président de la cour de cassation il
veut faire très beau
oui c'est possible je ne veux pas que
régis envoie un [ __ ]
cette précision c'est dur ainsi forcer
les racines ne pas vouloir être cocus
mais puisque je suis là pour ça pour
prendre la place de madame bec cependant
la petite formalités protocolaires et
donc vos activités
c'est une vocation un ton une sorte de
violon dad
et puis comme je voulais dire je suis
programmé pour ça et aussi pour ne pas
accepter de douceur est déjà prête à
paris c'est la journée maintenant aux
choses sérieuses le monde moderne
comment il faut que votre femme vit
comme une plaie elle est au courant des
normes importance de la visite que vous
attendez ce soir je vais garder ça pour
cet après midi avec un autre détail que
je suis pas pressé de lui apprendre j'ai
pas à quoi ça tient une plus de votre
lune de miel doit être loin derrière la
colline elle décline votre affaire
l'accepterai peut-être de se perdre dans
la nature le temps voulu en mettant les
choses empirent votre visiteur doit être
à orly demeure 0 ce que j'en dis c'est
pour vous
ça dépend jusqu'à quel point c'est
physique vous tient à coeur au plus haut
point et un cran au dessus pouvez-vous
nous a conduits en hachant entendre
cette embellie
auparavant vous n'y voyez pas
d'inconvénient s'est piqué une tête dans
la piscine avant des années ma vie est
ici vous étiez ici chez vous les
autorisations me semble superflu louis
vaquer à vos occupations
at on rappelé à autre chose mes bagages
dans l'antichute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vu passer l'hirondelle dans le ciel
pur dumas comme louie louie ya plus
personne
elle est partie le matin c'est dommage
oui c'est beau d'être je demande pas mal
de plaisanterie oui vous vous
accompagnerez mademoiselle jusqu'à la
chambre où la reine mathilde a fait une
fausse couche
non seulement j'ai payé ce château de
fortune a fallu que j'apprenne mon
histoire de force et j'aime autant vous
dire que la vie des équipes
ah ça c'est une bourriche qui m'a été
remise par le chauffeur de monsieur
l'ambassadeur je la portais à l'autisme
n'est ce pas deux bateaux sport c'est
fragile ces trucs là haut ils bougent
encore
arrêté le jour chez pied
bastille ce sont des pieds allez allez
rejoindre maritime bahia les cieux et
havelange manhattan padgett avoir
d'appétit ou bien plus bête au courant
grosso modo
de quelqu'un
quand je pense que j'ai produit d'être
une tombe croyait pas si bien dire
[Musique]
mais quatre tours
oui a reçu mon travail dit donc c'est
tout ce que vous allez négocier la tenue
comme avec cette taille a cassé on vous
savez monsieur trouver des objets ding
hao daming jour de marché au regard des
machines amical en rose mais ça apporte
une mère gigan c'est pourtant légalement
toute la fécondité à 20 avec jean pas
difficile comme ça mais ça vous plaira
les marchands qui me l'a dit j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer un véritable
ivoiriens qui vende les objets à la
sauvette et allait partir comme ça seul
une toile forcément un ivoire ne veut
pas se rendre compte
la paire garde du fleuve les simples
on copie qui sortent culminera à masquer
dedans alors essayez un peu pour voir
eva les temps c'est pas avec ça que vous
remplirez votre carnet de bal d'une
heure j'ai dû quelque chose pas ici du
duce qui tu as des pas demandé de
rapporter des cochonneries tel fethi ce
qui ramène la virilité bol de ramen la
virilité seul oui il nous a dit comment
on s'en servait n'ai pas osé lui
demander monsieur égoïste et ça qu'est
ce que c'est ce qu'ils disent ils c'est
la suite n'en voyant sa troisième chez
l'antiquaire saint gris gris d'un poil
gris et se sont avivées un gri gri gri
gri gri gri gri un gréviste un porte
bonheur
on dit que ça protège les jeunes filles
ça protège des jeunes fils
à
je vous en fais cadeau la presse map
vous être utile l'économie croît
fortement 4-4 avant goût oneapp à la fin
des bobos
est ce que tu fais jeter un climat
favorable à un climat typiquement
bantous on joue tous il vous genou
cadeau vous ma tante n'est pas la ville
tente peut-être je me permets de te
rappeler qu'avant le déjeuner à la fin
pour l'exposer tu nous a présenté
mademoiselle via la nouvelle madame bex
le sera seulement ce soir et que maman
devenait acer donc ma tante ta mère a
voulu racheter l'année afin de justifier
sa présence va faire passer pour ma
soeur elle pense que ce dîner sera plein
d'enseignements ne veut pas rater mon
petit albert est avant tout une grande
français de participer à ce qui va se
passer ce soir assister à l'événement
qui fera date par la grandeur et la
prospérité de notre pays et au savon aux
dés dans ce qui sera sans doute et de
grosses à l'art en bar et la france a il
est lent tu dis pas imaginer plus belle
coïncidence
qu'est ce que cette télé aujourd'hui
elle marche pas on s'en doute le banc en
40 ans de traque et l'antenne de son
effritement les enfants attention tout
le monde sur le pont chacun son poids
stéphane début un temps à ne pas faire
leur tour selon l'habitude bien que très
dur car c'est parce que trop mou après
leur bon vieux tu vas tous les gens
permanence c'est peut-être pour ça pas
par valve un seul instant je voulais
dire simplement que tu fais preuve d'une
telle vitalité qui a plus de place pour
un autre bête ya de la place pour
l'autre bex celle que tu te prépares tu
veux voir régner tu ne tournes que
l'enseignement
eh bien je me levais un jeune à son âge
j'étais déjà la tête de deux sociétés
que je t'avais apporté en dot
oui mais auparavant je t'avais enlevé
fallait le faire nos ongles aimable père
avait mis ses chiens aux trousses hop et
ça c'est pas une meute de dobermann qui
meurent fnh et deux sociétés
et limo petit mon mariage avec ta maman
était une grande et belle histoire
d'amour oui ce soir avec nous et avait
offert un petit pot talon alors sur tout
en même temps tu va occuper avec le
caporal les cuisines ont mitonné le bout
de notre invité de chez lui offrir un
petit dîner surprise quelque chose qui
me rappelle un peu son pays face à face
à écouter imaginez notre joie suis au
coeur de l'afrique on vous présentait
tout à coup une entrecôte bord de l'ex
c'est un peu ça l'idée
nous a appris que les tiennes et déjà
avec les cousins
moi j'appelle ça de satan petit le ciel
tiens on va la femme au gris gris est-ce
qu'il va pas pour payer des problèmes
non monsieur je voulais simplement vous
demander quel serait mon rôle durant
dîner ont encore la joue et pourquoi ça
fera musée de faire partie de la famille
vous assisterez au dîner ça fera une
femme de plus vous jouez le rôle de sud
c'est lui qui vous convient le mieux et
si cassé phase qui va arriver lui a fait
tant de mystère pendant le repas va-t-on
enfin nous dire de quelle république il
est le président j'ai voulu le talent
manga 1 le polonais sans vous tout juste
augure aux dieux du sien c'est une
blague
ce tyran ce despote sanguin ballon m'a
tant qu'il ne fait pas ses m'attendais
oui la lazio a oui je m'entraîne la
wetab mieux faire une belle frappe lundi
les rouleurs alors mais voyons reste ma
tante
tu n'as jamais eu l'occasion de
rencontrer hitler et pourtant
papa avait construit le mur de
l'atlantique un tout petit bout
vallée du ciment j'en ai trouvé et à la
libération bâti déteste la politique je
dois m'inscrire à un pas deux parties
j'ai dépensé une fortune en cotisations
il est vrai que le colonel sens pourrait
perfectionner le système il ne limoge
pas ses ministres il les envoie au
crocodile rock au goûter le jus lowepro
connu mais alors c'était un petit sous
secrétaire d'état
il a fait manger par les crocodiles
sacrés hennion sinon on fait toute une
histoire
il y avait 10 janvier son ami d'enfance
mais c'est trop les jours d'un scandale
qu on a vu les images au journal de la
une la kabylie jouera finale à la france
tu prends des messages codés les savoir
en tant que dictateur sait tous leurs
problèmes ils règlent comme il l'entend
moi je suis un libéral
j'ai pas à m'en mêler des tuniques ou
tops le proto comme un type charmant
ah oui charmant par un délicieux cultivé
et respectueuse qui n'est pas pour me
déplaire
des traditions de ses aïeux tu as tu te
rappelles de leçon et cuite web
je n'y manquerai pas bon haute tension
ce soir le grand tralala investissent
beaucoup de femmes comme versailles
nous pouvons disposer oui j'ai un
contrat à étudier allons-y ma tante le
pétrole le pétrole du latin petra pierre
et oleum une roulée où l'on se rend
football est ouvert aux une amie avoir à
tourner en noir ne mâche n'est pas ici
comme typiques ont pour principaux
gisements connus
il verrait fed sont fait ressentir au
koweit gisement se poser je faisais
juste rupture géologique sédimentaires
ribéry somme l angola talent gargotes et
une tension aménagé mouvante et
d'industrie dans la fondation stand eu
les utilisations multiples des produits
dérivés du pétrole
clairement aux états unis que la
consommation annuelle est admise 700 kg
de produits pétroliers par habitant a
reçu des consignes maintenant et non pas
notre atout dans le ciboulot
les noirs sont de grands enfants tous
ceux qui parlent l'effacement soumettre
au jeu à la tentation
qu'est ce que nous avons en lingots d'or
pour la chambre forte à 2 100 de la
banque de france boissons à jour 3 bars
de la federal bande sans oublier les
émeraudes ailleurs elles vont s'envoler
ce soir pour un long voyage dans tous
les créneaux sur la peau billy mon
pauvre père qui était dans le prêt à
porter tu sais toujours si l'affairé
bound ce qu'elle peut être meilleur le
champion lieu un pote ma casquette mais
pas d'allonger jamais la grosse bise
rase-mottes l'envergure d'un canari et
moi je dis où le père a passé le fils
doit dépasse 8 bastien bex vd la banque
de retraite mineurs de 5000 aux 500
millions aux sucettes au porteur et sur
les explications et les suppléments
optique un peu de bienvenue pour la
réalisation d'un contrat personnel que
je les joints en douce au traité de
cession dit le petit [ __ ] vont
travailler en douce au qi de la ration
d'un soldat copeaux millions entraînant
le cac floch leur a parlé et qu'on peut
viser le tapis surtout quand cet appui
et celui des mille et une nuits
voiture qui l'invitait de monsieur est
en train de franchir la grille ne durent
2 août
je suis tenu d'un microphone c'est une
voiture officielle ds noire avec aucun
des deux motards partage chefs d'état se
déplace en trottinette
sa majesté la reine des pays bas ne
détaille pas l'usagé de la bicyclette
entendre un peu vous dit pas tape deux
enfants allez on va la sonate à son
arrivée en aucun cas d'enseignants non
non tu te dire guerre war et quand vous
commettez une grande et un depraeter
secrète le cinquième à paris la carrière
tout y est encore la distinction lagrave
st
[Applaudissements]
maintenant de là vécu
riesch
p
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour ne devrait pas tarder il est
déjà parti depuis 20 minutes avec le
président ils n'ont pas en effet son
absence devient bizarre maintenant la
pépine attend le colonel n'est pas là
c'est inutile il met infiniment plus
agréable de m'imaginer que ma tante et
non ma mère s'est prêté à cette
mascarade et je trouverais hautement
morale que le gros s'envolant refuse sa
signature après tout ce cirque qui en
est témoin de trouver votre humour à
rien vincent jeune homme il y à un
élément dont votre d'ignorer vol semble
faire bien peu de cas c'est la france
qui va m'arracher de la hanche
l'ambassadeur laisser son privilège à la
jeunesse je nomme je trouve moi votre
réaction très saine et fort plaisante
c'est un peu comme une bouffée d'air pur
dans cette équipe et mais qui ne croyez
moi ils me bluette comparé à tout ce qui
se trame se complotent s'ourdit chaque
jour un peu partout dans le monde alors
c'est le monde qu'il convient de changer
à mes dépends sont sans cesse soyez en
persuader et oui et non à n'en pas
douter les visions non ce n'est pas de
mots - croyez-vous vraiment que tout est
en train de bien se passer
alors cet honneur appartiendra à la
petite histoire le précieux petrojet un
hangar sera propriété légitime de notre
gouvernement jusqu'au dernier mais 10
litres et bex aura enlevé d'un cru de
plus son contrat de modalités de salaire
qui est entre les mains d'un profiteur
serait une malédiction pour la main
d'oeuvre talent guez concerne c'est à
dire les trois quarts de sa population
mais qui dans les mains de monsieur
votre mari sera un instrument de travail
et de progrès qui est engagée envers moi
solennel alors puisque personne ne
semble douter du résultat sauf vous
peut-être mademoiselle sudre on quitte
rien pour ce n'est pas mon rôle je me
suis arrivé trop me demander mon avis
crois en effet que coup de plume sera
donné mais un peu grâce aux huit bars
nord et aux 3 et broad que je suis allé
chercher dans la chambre surgissent fort
de la nuit ici est assez logique la
mettre le feu l'étiquette papa la vie
tout chef d'état reçu et pour amener de
nuit accroît son camp mais c'est un fait
que lorsque le sénat romain recevait 16
heures de nuit
ils envoyaient à sa rencontre deux
éléphants porteurs de torche à bouts de
troncs le jardin d'acclimatation n'ayant
pas eu le temps de me livrer ses trompes
je remplace les six élus avantageusement
et bien tu signé à l'heure qu'il est la
france va posséder le pétrole a manqué
c'est peut-être seulement un homme
d'affaires célèbre mais encore la
diplomate dans la grande tradition du 14
mai je me défends bien
raconte-nous vie suffit très beau très
chaud mark xiii dire qu'un jour les
petits enfants dans les églises et dans
les écoles apprendront par coeur le
récit de sept sièges sud
je suis si plus nous étions debout
derrière une table qui allait devenir
historique nous l'avions sorti mon stylo
et vous avez signé dans les échanges et
les stylos d'udinese ont paraît-il
oui en effet mais d'ordinaire des
changes a lieu après la signature devant
allah lui l'a voulu à vendre la
confiance le stylo du colonel sabow mais
c'est un vulgaire style où en est bonne
tu ne vas pas moi fait tomber des têtes
qui le tient par un que ton nom ainsi
doublé platines pour une fois tu aimes
vous êtes fait rouler après mon fiston
de ce fait j'allais rouler quand on sait
à la france et qu'on la perte est
compensée par un bénéfice sans vie par
tous importants actes dont il a
également exigé le chronomètre en or qui
ornait mon poignet tort une tradition
saint paul a à ma connaissance non avant
alors vous avez
en afrique les palabres ne vont pas
suivi il a décoré du mérite tellement ça
m'a aussi ben moi aussi et vous n'êtes
pas commandeur mois le colonel m'a élevé
à la dignité de grand cordon avec busy
sur les joues non sur la bouche
oui oui le grand cordon à droite au bc
fraternelle soulage les lèvres du
colonel était-elle sua
mais on peut pas dire ce sont ces
affaires sont les affaires non les
affaires de la france bien entendu
heureusement la signature alors j'ai
fait deux passes dont je fus grand
pardon
le colonel pris mon stylo en or massif
toutes les deux platines ce ton chat sur
aux traités y signant donc il se mit à
danser à chanter à criel de bango
cha-cha-cha bongo bongo il était devenu
fou
non il invoquer son dirty kids ou
hôpital avait la divinité titre aucune
commerce
le producteur belge et des filous il
abat les deux faisceaux son top compris
alors par discrétion
je me suis retiré sur la pointe des
pieds laisse le canada avec son dieu 10
kg et laura prudent que même en cas de
difficultés de leurs alter d'un coup de
pouce
ça fait cinq ou six devaient pas besoin
font l'affairé est dans le sac
en effet j'ai fait traîner dans la piège
bobards d'or et nos héros dans quelques
instants n'aura à voir venir avec le
contrat signé pro dit ogier de vue
monsieur permis un petit essai grèce n 1
ça illumine le visage tout sourire c'est
ce fait le bal à l'état un peu pendant
le repas pour les connaisseurs à dieu
de sexologie des sandwichs de son
excellence le président madame qu'elle
scinde week
mademoiselle viaur a cru comprendre que
son excellence seraient désireuses d'en
porter pour son voyage à londres demain
une manière d'en cas confectionné avec
les reliefs de la pièce de venaison elle
atteint en guest reconnaître qu il aille
ses souffrances c'est pas votre avis
valent aussi madame sourire prix bien
volontiers
on n'en trouvera pas je me suis demandé
quel pouvait être ce gibier délicieux
d'ailleurs est indéfinissable mais nous
sommes en juin la chasse n'est-elle pas
fermé en effet bonhomme alors lucien
plus ya mis du sien a dit que tu es tu
là pq lors qu'elle était ce gibier qu'on
vous a servi ce soit lui juifs oui
mj l'île maurice était due du mouflon
un mouflon un vieux mouflon on a droit
au chenal de chasse et mouflons et
j'aime tellement les expressions quillan
fois quand il juge ce gibier et ils
veulent ou wii ou bien au contraire et l
avenue avait-il du corps
et pas qu il fait une chaleur incroyable
vous déçu qu il est vrai que j'avais une
feinte d'entrepôts stark
je ne sais plus encline aux juges
qu'avez vous vous êtes tout pâle
seriez-vous souffrent 7la foot ici bas
soirée dansante un peu d'air frais vous
fera du bien
quelle idée aussi de servir à footy dans
un grand dîner si on m'avait laissé
faire oui vous êtes content de votre
travail au lorsque lundi que de monsieur
sera parti je demanderai la permission
de ne plus la portée ne parlait pas à la
légère louis le révérend père nous a
expliqué tout à l'heure qu'elle nous
donnaient droit ou présentez armes des
facs sol air ôta manga avec là je fais
voyage pour me payer ça je suppose que
la cuisinière a aussi sacré oui la même
madame mais avec des glaives atteignant
le contrat à l'écart des routes
il m'a renvoyé à la force vive à voter
sud de la loire je suis sûr que tu veux
il joue mécano avec ses barres d'or et
aux billes avec les émeraudes
en dehors de ces enfantillages
rien d'autre ma robe n'a pas un faux pli
et aucune mèche de ma coiffure la subite
outrage
je vous laisse conclure c'est impossible
quand je voudrais jamais laisser seul
avec lui tous les espoirs étaient permis
il m'a fait asseoir à ses côtés mais
c'était pour lui tendre ces joujoux
enfin avez-vous vraiment fait comme on
lirait jeu tout le nécessaire
monsieur l'ambassadeur dont l'échec
le premier il suffisamment vexant est
invraisemblable je vous demande de ne
pas ajouter à mon humiliation en mettant
en doute ma conscience professionnelle
mais quand elle va mal c'est votre
ordinateur quand je mets en doute
il a dit vous programmez uniquement pour
les jours de soldes de la samaritaine
mais c'est en effet inimaginable
mais comment un homme peut-il vous
résistez ouvert vous n'êtes peut-être
pas le mieux placé pour porter un
jugement de ces temps pour être père
blanche d'un support - un homme bombay
que veut-il vous non il ne veut moi
petit aux geôliers
c'est noël
ça il veut vous voir ouais pourquoi en
dieu il ne m'a pas fait la grâce de
mieux dit j'y vais le cas était prévu
dans le protocole monsieur l'ambassadeur
vous c'est pas le genre à vous d'aller
très vite vous dans la terre noire
j'aurais dû lui dire te rapporter ton
style mais c'est broadway le ski l'eau
va servir il ne s'agit que d'une
péripétie
rien n'est perdu croyez moi non le
colonel est un grand enfant facétieux il
a même fait des niches à la reine
d'angleterre lors c'est dire tu par la
reine d'angleterre pépère
c'est dur c'est pourquoi il ne faut pas
t'énerver je trouve en tout cas son
attitude est extrêmement désobligeantes
à l'égard de mademoiselle c'est
incompréhensible
c'est qu'a dit on s'en fout du monde
mettra et vous répondez dans notre champ
là aviez vous sur moi mais non mais non
voyons
nous essayons tous des chefs dans notre
profession elle pourrait devenir la
dernière fois il a tenu tête au monde
entier pendant un an
il ne vous résiste qu'un soir à halle
mais ce qu'ils vont faire
non non merci mon père puis je vous
demander de nous laisser seuls en
instance nous je vais en profiter pour
dire mes heures à la belle étoile
alors alors c'est pas chaude à ces
coiffes à chopin
peinture kwassa fachoda cela signifie
que nous allons déjà long ils sont pas
encore là car dira t on
ce que je suis en train de parler bout
du quai ce qui peut et doit écouter
monsieur alex je considère une aventure
comme terminée nous essuyé un échec
voilà tout prix voilà tout et mon nom
mais ses propos monsieur temps d'état
acceptent les syndicats
je savais ce que ça représente cours
officiel et parallèle mais je ne voulais
pas dire ça parce que vous le dire war
et dans toutes les vallées du bon un
détail de vous les faire récupérer vous
avez mal compris la pensée de l'autre si
sûr comme ça évidemment évidemment il ya
un petit risque il avaler mais émeraude
peut-être bon monsieur que je n'ai pas
le coeur à plaisanter moi j'ai toutes
les raisons de fond là mais vous et moi
nous sommes unis dans l'échec comme nous
n'avons j'étais dans la nuit à ceci près
qu'un becks ne connaît pas les chèques
donc votre fonds syrah syrah d'avoir été
si vous vous tenez vraiment à savoir où
les je fasse subir des brancards
vous décidez à part évolué et bien voilà
oh mon dieu que c'est difficile voilà
voilà
il a été il a été très touché que vous
mettiez aussi spontanément votre femme à
sa discrétion mais aussi invraisemblable
que cela paraisse nora ne lui plaît pas
c'est qu'il n'est pas normal votre cus
nous avons commis une erreur
psychologique nous aurions dû penser que
partout où il va on sépare de lui servir
ce qui existe de mieux sur le marché les
madame claude tous les pays du monde
sont sur les dents pour fournir au
colonel la fine fleur de leur cheptel
dès qu'ils posent en un clé dans leur
capital alors alors alors et alors
et alors toujours du caviar salaces
avait personnellement de noir et gant
on sera devant vous ne voulez vraiment
par comprendre où vous le faites exprès
jeune âge alors accrochez vous bien car
vous risquez de couler et le souhaitent
une femme plus que tu vu plus plus
réservés
oui on enfin en un mot il trouve votre
soeur très à son goût
c'est ça ma soeur
régime vous l'avez c'est ma femme
ah oui mais pour lui c'est votre soeur
vous foutez de moi non vous voyez bien
que c'est impossible loin possible c'est
pire que ça monsieur monstrueux avec
l'action ça vous dit tout
on revient également dans la rue pour me
demander ça à moi pardon pardon c'est à
moi qu'il demandait même de société ça
c'est bien qu'ils auraient pu vous en
parler directement qui peut le plus peut
le moins
il a dirigé la femme ils pouvaient
demander dassault lui refuser sera dû
faire un affront aux sa vanité et qui
mal à y est je vous l'avais précisément
phénol dans parlons jamais habitants
parlent offrez-vous apparent plus et non
par un peu
apparemment plus lent parlons plus
et puis disent peut-être demander son
avis à réchy parus après tout ne leur
ont pas pouvoir de décision en coûtera
jeu les pouvoirs de ma fonction
majorettes ou des limites imposées dans
la morale la plus élémentaire
je crois plus à dire quoi que ce soit la
seule demande à gilles devenir un
instant je te ferai le lui permet un
mois
comment madame benbassa l'heure c'est
une affaire entre sa conscience et ça
nous regarde le qu'une façon venu de
laisser jouer comme il vous plaira
bien entendu je n'ai pas besoin de
demander la plus grande discrétion
alors là vous me sens est véritablement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les mots petit assieds toi mon petit
comme tu es sur la neige mon petit frère
ça y est fait signer j'en étais sûr j'ai
senti tu sais qu'ils les postes encore
trop tard dans la saison pour que nous
donnions à grand dîner pour célébrer ça
c'est vrai quoi ta cause est indigne aux
flambeaux pas petite tape sur la pelouse
avec justement le fameux cuissots
devenait en lattes à l'envié que nous
faisons c'est à dire par des piqûres en
libre et avec le corps des débouchés
dans doit se cacher dans le parc ce
nom-là dampierre et le salut à
saint-hubert aussi pas une bonne idée
une très bonne idée malheureusement elle
est y réalisa pas ça si je te le demande
bien voilà je t'écoute ma chérie le
colonel n'a pas signé vous pouvez lui
mettez barres d'or des hymnes prêt
d'argent n'est pas mortelle alors c'est
raté hahaha
tu as encore une chance petit petit
aujourd'hui si je t'aimais ne te
respecter comme je t'aime je te respecte
qu'est ce que j'y ai toujours quitter
entre tes mains l'avenir du talent
gueule et serait que la bible de la
france moi j'avais les boules modèle
lors de tout seul et d'abnégation à bout
qu'est ce que je dois faire
délicieuse kreider magnifique pureté que
je ne souffrirai pas ou par les paroles
plaisant tu ne saura jamais pourquoi
n'as tu fais c'est joli ce
méphistophélès du quai d'orsay mal moi
de te parler
alors j'ai fait semblant d'accepter pour
le pâtis hérité du rôle l'instant était
trop grave
on a trop dit ou pas assez si le droit
de savoir
un jour peut-être je te raconterai cette
histoire qui alors nous fera bien rire
j'aimerais dire tout de suite
saab était dans un très bon et puis toi
ploeren enfin pas bhl lucien tu sais
très bien que tu peux tout dire et tout
me demander
répète que tu viens de dire que tu peux
tout me demander quand tu me dussault
parce que c'est la vérité tu veux pas
faire allusion à cette promesse que tu
m'avais fait après une escapade avec le
marquis de bris car les siens ya quinze
ans de cela qu'il avait promis qu'on en
parlerait jamais plus je tenu parole me
suis jeté dessus de toi qui faisait lui
son bilan c'est très bien je t'ai rien
passé entre le mark et moi d'aller juré
sur la tête de maman rappelle annette sa
mort
mais je n'ai jamais vu de la parole en
doute mon jury jamais alors qu'est ce
que tu me demandes
meriem ne sait rien du tout y est
tellement de rien lucien je ne sortirai
pas du sien tuner parler préfères-tu que
j'attends suite et jaune alors tu
attends ça ne craint pas de cette terre
par plusieurs toits que cette dette
canal est venu me trouver de la part du
colonel donc demandé c'était plus non
non non tu devineras part mais je ne
cherchais pas tu sais qu'on aura lui a
pas plu mais difficile et pourtant c'est
un homme de coups
[Musique]
il va en avoir la preuve
figure parmi les plus values ils
préfèrent les femmes à la fois plus mûr
et plus réservée
c'est son droit n'est ce pas et alors
c'est tout est bien de nommer une femme
mûre est réservé c'est pas bête sous
j'ai compris aux plus anciens
il veut sudre
et tu me demandes de la mettre en
condition c'est bien ça tue l
imagination de toi je te jure
tiens j'y pensais plus à celle là alors
qu'ils qui n'ont jusqu'à 10 mois que
c'est pas vrai que je vais le laisse pas
chéri de colette trouve irrésistible
demande pas de morts merci merci tu m'as
fait très peur mois dans les bras de ses
dictateurs semblant d'humour encore lh2
que j'ai rien non plus au front coûte
une action innocence
moi je n'ai trouvé beaucoup de charme
c'est pourtant quelle attaque blanc qui
n'a vu ce livre et j'étais ministre
crocodile illégal à tout journaliste
qu'est ce qu'on raconte moi dans le lit
de ce cannibale moi tu sais ça pourquoi
tu le trait de khôl est bonne parce
qu'il en est certainement capa
mais j'aurais jamais cru tenir entre
mille pauvre main un destin d'une telle
important des stades à francs lucien tu
m'as fait rappeler ma promesse tout à
l'heure ça n'est pas par hasard si tu te
prends tu lui as folk quoi caméra avec
toi je t'en prie
comment peux-tu supposer un seul instant
que vous serez capable de proposer un
tel sacrifice
moi marie tudor amaro de penser une
chose pareille mais pour quelle raison
je te demande pour quelle raison pour
quels avantages
quoi la france la fausse évidemment
n'aura pas dans le monde une place
prépondérante que la portance du lot s
il était brouillé ça va jusqu'à présent
non sans blague bien sûr il y aura pas
de dispensable sadek soudain mon gars
les pauvres noirs resteront dans leur
misère et je ne présenterai pas la
députation à tous les plateaux et oui
oui oui bah oui vous avez une grande
chance d'être député une battue ne sera
jamais la femme d'un ministre or quant à
ma rosette et s'est envolé m'amuser à
des médias qui pensent pas le droit
on ne parle plus tb cas c'est bien
pourquoi du modèle comme ça attends je
rachète un champ à tonton je te vois
venir
je la vois venue elle est capable de
voumard s'immoler ce sacrilège me
connais ton côté jadart tu fais ton côté
marie madeleine ça je te ferai tout pour
tout en empêchant tout bois tantôt et
n'insiste pas
aussi tous les clichés du penser qu'il
s'agit là d'un devoir sacré de cinq
missions que si elle t'a confié est
serré
je suis né de la frontière je n'ai
qu'une parole
résidant sur régine je te défends les
siens bon foot m'en fous de ça passera
plutôt tendue qui bafoue lucien battant
au petit matin
j'ai honte et mois d'août
je
je saurai peut-être pas il s'occupera de
tout je sais bien que je ne compte pas
beaucoup je me sacrifie enfin on
sacrifie tout les deux maintenant c'est
un peu à moi hein ça t'aidera
le petit pavillon à gauche en sortant
[Applaudissements]
que monsieur me pardonne j'ai entendu
crier monsieur monsieur désir au
monsieur et tout pâle est il malade d'un
mois le moment à passer quand tout
oui certainement monsieur l'amour pas si
monsieur le pense c'est pour la france
monsieur veut-il que j'appelle le
docteur clavier un support manager
totalement du passé les ppre ont pour
nom monsieur ne va jamais trop loin
il m'a prouvé qu'il pouvait tout oser
bonsoir monsieur parlez-moi lui parlez
moi de laisser passer l'eau ce moment
monsieur s'est beaucoup dépensé
aujourd'hui oui rassurez moi vos quêtes
pauvres dont connecte les pas vrai et
pas vrai que je suis le plus grand salon
de la terre je répondrai à monsieur que
monsieur a toujours été à la pointe du
progrès
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
capcom
vous échappe
que se passe t'il encore changer d'idée
vous pouvez cueillir les fruits du
sacrifice cependant nous sommes deux
pour la cueillette remplir le petit
panier
madame bec fait une excellente
ambassadrice insinue
l'ariana dit non il n'a pas daigné la
prime adam beach d'une main et m'a tendu
le marocain de l'eau nous avons fini par
l'avoir
ce babou ont pris le café ripper si ça
qui se passe en ce moment des mouches
iphone qu elle pas un peu où un jeune
devrait pas retrouver votre place face à
ma femme le soir à la veillée les nuits
d'hiver sont longs j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
de trois pignons et bâtisseur les jeudis
les êtres d'exception s'était perdue
dans les nuances et les subtilités rien
de prendre et été accomplis dans le lac
le résultat bon
j'appelle oui nous avons savez le
champagne pour fêter les deux camps
excellente idée en panne exceptionnelle
pour événements exceptionnels
j'entends parler de champagne suis-je de
la fête généralement voyons fait patte
chefs d'état civil pour deviner mais pas
perdu tes c'est le vieux dicton l'habit
ne fait pas le moine
j'ai bien failli rentrer dans les jambes
mais la divine drass a tourné court
et s'il ne pas perdre du désert c'est
que vous êtes des services spéciaux aaa
vous voyez que pour les devinettes
jettera personnes entre à des
compliments qui devront lutter plus vrai
que nature nous pour qu'avec ce qu'il
fallait c'est quand même quelque chose
qui m'échappe
le colonel notre dispensaire au canada
le colonel connaît parfaitement ma
véritable identité
on prend plus ajoutons patience puis-je
allumé la télé est en panne elle ne
l'est plus un fils de l'antenne ont été
sectionnés quelque chose qui ressemblait
tant le sabotage mais nous avons réparé
arioso rébus depuis l'émission star
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
regardez aujourd'hui
justement que c'est cette orientation
des cours donnés je me rappelle en
prétendant marre
les polonais de sang vos attentes
quand vous avez pu le constater le
colonel d'un poney
ces applaudissements et son bonheur ont
plaisir à pas s'était imposé en direct
de l'opéra direct à vous les studios
il était temps elle me nettoie nous leur
étions avouer que c'eut été dommage
alors le noir du là n'est pas le colonel
sampo la figure à mon cher mais vous
avez vu cette allure sa dignité
un doublement cette secte majesté et ce
qui ne gâche rien cinq ans barman sur le
france il à la désaffectation de cette
belle unité 12h permis de récupérer ce
parfait sosie du colonel maintenu un
héros des services spéciaux et la
lumière fut
travailleur indépendant mon cher mais
africaine consacrée c'est de plus mais
les pourris de ton espèce ça le sert de
salle au vous ne m'aurez pas tout le
moribond est logée par des grilles
lâcher les chiens puis trajet ils vont
répondre je crois que vous prenez une
benne inutile
nous ne sommes pas des amateurs en chute
libre norad et à l'emploi ne vous le
fais pas dire
dia pièce habitude je planais encore
dans l'euphorie alors mais bon vous
voyez 30 août où vous allez finir la
nuit
mal notée tendue dans nos lits douillets
quant aux autres où on nous promet du
grand palais d'ici une heure à dieu est
maintenant aux hommes de dieu cause on
consent d'abord pris ma femme aux bons
soins de temps colonel quelque part sur
la côte normande mois il peut être la
caution élémentaires pour le cas fort
improbable au foot vous montreriez pas
qu'aux pirates est belle je ne
m'inquiète pas des quais ne nous ont
quittés bons amis
elle vous reviendra piratage n'est pas
du menu fretin grand chalon des couleurs
je l'étais déclenché une sonnette
d'alarmé la fine fleur de la gendarmerie
tu arrêteras dans le quart d'heure pour
vous remettre un créneau la police lui
hérité des logements vides déclencher
des bons princes
in fine aval pour appeler vos trophées
du copain mais tout ce qui va emporter
par étourderie bon d'or des bijoux mais
est trop dans ce pays d'auge mettant les
siens sans oublier ma femme qui l a
entendu on se serre la main ciao bye bye
sayonara quelque chose comme une paix
blanc à la fed ont l'honneur et la
dignité du point qui conte et puis si
vous n'êtes pas partir du puits si vous
êtes une petite idée derrière la tête
une grande idée jacques higelin
filigramme citrouille après les joies de
l'escroquerie des douceurs du chantage
abject ne pas s'offrir la tempête de
ricoh n'at-il déchaînerait en déposant
la plainte du siège journalistes nous
ferait élever une statue on aurait une
page entière dans le dictionnaire des
farceurs le grand méchant loup qui se
fait mais comparé à café de coccinelles
trop heureux de son recul noté en
silence et de payer l'amant c'est ça la
combine amicaux vous brûlez campagne et
sauf que c'est du pipi
combine de pipi qu'avant je n'y aurais
oublié de vous préciser je fus très
sombre de l éthique la totalité de nos
entretiens mot pour mot depuis la minute
des tomates a ici jusqu'à celle où les
filles vont venir vous que dire garder
tourne encore leribault johnny ou qu'en
pensez vous quelques dommages par ci par
là quelques repiquage artistique je
pense de vierges et tel est pris qui
croyait prendre
comptant comme sa camarade au no 9 vrai
positivement j'enverrai ma photo à fred
avec une dédicace
une punaise pour la crosse et on
reviendra avec la mention destinataire
inconnu à cette adresse et vous
traversez dans les poudres et de
l'électro magnétique journée notre
matériel pourrait prendre fin quand
l'europe en avait pas moins aussi
efficace nous avons nous aussi un joli
flot de rubans sea paru hors sur la
madone monfils
regardez micro haute fidélité et quant
aux banques qui leur paraît les coupures
que vous souhaitez feront leur petit
chemin dans quelques rédactions à gros
tirage il y aura de la joie fut bien je
vous aurais dit vous nous avez moon a
les éléments sur les bancs attention je
présente pas à 3 2 3
et
vous n'allez tout de même pas qu'après
deux années de préparation minutieuse
nous aurions pu commettre une pari foot
donc ce doux agents motocyclistes ne
sont pas seulement là pour le décorum
sont de vrais professionnels
c'est tout le monde aimait bien
m'excuser à nommer olof vous recevrez
quand même votre exemplaire numéroté
donne envie d'entendre et d'attendre à
deux séquences
le mytho d'agents du contrôle demandeur
pour l'exploitation des mines mohamed la
mise en place du petit disons tête à
tête destiné à convaincre votre épouse
de se ruer au sacrifice de quoi amuser
entre autres votre fils si nous devions
à dieu ne plaise en arriver là
outrepasse il l'a dit à dieu ne plaise
gros bêta tout ça c'est encore du
conditionnel ou au conditionnel aussi la
diffusion des grandes séquences des
vraies séquences de choc la gappe le
festin le cuissot de venaison à la ta
langue pour ce bobard il faudra repasser
si vous n'êtes pas diplomate eu que six
tours à ne pas perdre leur logique et
les ballons qu'il adore du maire
monsieur avec s'il est relativement
facile moyennant annonay de bakchich de
se procurer une fesse humaine dans
n'importe quelle amphithéâtre de
dissection de l'école de médecine n'ont
aucun mal à vous prouver qu'il n'ya pas
eu tromperie sur la marchandise je
n'avais qu'à le faire analyser
d'autre part au moins la femme fatale en
bouffer mon paroisse comme vous dites va
sur ses 45 ans il est né à l'âge d'or ou
loin des blancs dans le mystère de la
jungle
on ne serait pas les futurs guerrier
avec du poulet et vous n'avez pas
remarqué que notre cher nora et moi même
n'avons pas touché à se briser deux
missionnaires grands honneurs avec moi
et elle est pourquoi cet heureux parce
qu'il était nécessaire que cela fût
vraiment de la viande humaine afin de
vous fassiez votre vie durant elle a
digéré été vue à savoir jusqu'où vous
pouviez descendre en acceptant vous nous
avez administré la preuve que nous
avions raison
la douane en leur humain le plus néfaste
et le plus méprisable kaniba
prévaricateurs proxénète de sa propre
femme tout pour plaire j'allais oublier
vous préciser que nos banques risquent
de s'ennuyer tout seul nous leur
donnerons pour compagnie quelques foot
prise en ce moment même des ébats coloré
extraconjugaux de madame votre office
risk olemps tard que je sentais que ce
monsieur sont d'excellents 3e dan de
karaté c'est pourquoi comparer aux
matériels en notre possession les
babioles que nous avons récupéré n'apas
continue quand même à loire le plus
mauvais tout prix la clé la clé est le
petit numéro du coffre en suisse
si je suis complètement vidé mais
mentalement car vous devez continuer
monsieur l'ex afin de nous apporter
votre contribution trimestrielle lors
les bijoux c'était pour s'amuser et si
je préférais figure clochard lui de
vache à lait qui savait l'attraper vous
qui seriez punit ceux qui ne l'oublions
pas l'essentiel de notre mission et
l'argent n'est qu'un petit dédommagement
pour le dérangement une sorte de
defrasnes miyama fiable connaissez la
mafia il commande un temps les pilot
qu'il est de ma vie il sera bien vous
retrouver un jour ou l'autre
où que vous soyez moyennant larges
rétributions sans dire vous ne croyez
pas ça à dossier complet de cette
affaire sera déposée dans un coffre
discret avec or de n'ouvrir que sur la
vue de nos actes de décès alors souhaité
nous longuefuye nous vous téléphoneront
demain nous avons décroché dans la
galerie les quelques toiles qui en était
digne
vous aurez la bonté de nous en faire
donation allions oublier l'essentiel au
pour l'amour de l'art
si vous le voulez bien attendez
comment puis-je être assuré de votre
silence et rions nous dit tu es la poule
aux oeufs d'or
[Musique]
le champagne monsieur ces messieurs ne
doivent pas être loin je le sers ici non
alors où monsieur montre où vous voudrez
à la pi 6 po paris j'aimerais que
monsieur précise en foutez moi la paix
ou 2 couches et je ne prendrai pas ma
veste pare que monsieur envisage de se
priver de mes services hors de question
qu'il ne soit qu'ils n'estiment à nous
rappeler délicieuse mois que je ne suis
pas à ma place dans ce château en béton
vous à la foule vous êtes le sachet de
l'avant la morano merci monsieur et à
quelle heure dois-je réveiller monsieur
[Musique]
un stock de cauchemar des eaux
les sandwichs qui auraient oublié
dois-je leur place aux réfrigérateurs
monsieur poser votre plateau
aller frapper à tout seul ou des culs de
descendre immédiatement ma vie siècle
vient de se pencher là dans la couveuse
elle va fumer demain la couveuse suis
dit hé oui monsieur j'y vais j'y vais
tout de suite on croit que les riches
ont soif d'argent c'est faux il le
boivent sans soif croire québec sa soif
d'argent c'est comme croire que le côté
de parc da soit deux places avec ce tas
d'argent de l'argent celui des autres
via su sauter comme un fleuve reimer a
été lu dans lequel rouler dans la farine
aplati posséder cartonné c'est vrai mais
ils ont tous pliés comme te fais jamais
touché les deux épaules
j'avais vaincu bex est ce qu'ils font
est plutôt comment québec le souffle la
belle elle est le souffle
même si la polémique règne sur la nuque
et sont les yeux fatale que le moteur
tourne à tous personnes avancé la nage
contact up décollage pour rentrer avant
le bout de la tester bijouterie on ans
tu vas pas un bex le côté hokusai
boomerang
ce champ géant flouze la collecte des
bacs si tu la connais france touchera
cas c'est parti mon kiki est parti c'est
bon ça ça s'appelle fraîcheur d'oseille
la voilà la poubelle le voile la bouche
suit toujours le petit sud redoux
enfants que j'espère il faut bien
monsieur revel sud mardi
c'est ici dans ma peau c'est toute la
meilleure attention d'abord petit
chauffage les bras sans oublier ce
qu'ils ont oublié
prenez d'efforts au mercy me 6 nuls et
monsieur nouveau
nous avons bon faire bloc la masse qu
ils voudront tiennent pas à travailler
ce soir vous urbain kojima si il veut
il est là le bébé icogne il veut sortir
allez-y justement de les finir
elle a beau aimer ça les améliore au nom
de notre samba qui gagne mais ça madame
va pas voyez donc ça elle n'aimait pas
les voir s'en aller
très bon joueur c'est surtout ce petit
goût de noisette montbrun diez plus à
remplacer leurs avis et surannée donnant
3 2 dans la creuse magnifique
vous n'avez pas bien c'est du droit des
jo c'est tout simplement de l'homme
belhout de l'eau à chevaux
du vulgaire au moins ça pieux nationale
men pourrait lui ravir
quand je soulève pour vous le rideau de
la migration
à l'heure où sylvine les cavernes de
l'âge de pierre
j'aimerais sortir ta ne la condamnez
mendiants l'ultime cigarettes a sans
doute commis à son premier paquet et
louis saez
quant à mme antier lui a appris qu'il
venait de se taper la pitance à cochons
il a dû devenir vert gazon eux c'est pas
ta qu'il est mort nous et d'appartements
savez vous que vous ne l'avez jamais
bouffée de leurs restaurants bars et
restaurants quand le chef sous couple
doit une seconde madère et le bourgogne
bivb de chicago
quand quelqu'un maladroite dit qu'une
bête dont les moines heures si tu te
glisse on l'abordé hachoir
forbach a zo bet à monsieur dhr
pouvez-vous juré devant dieu dans les
sommes que vous n'avez jamais mangé
georges et hop on en a mangé monsieur le
procureur
et c'était bon et c'était bon tort était
de gauche voilà la réponse du témoin
chez le procureur
à vous de juger mais je jouais si avoir
un steak de son prochain dans l'estomac
et plus répréhensibles ou d'avoir un
coeur de son prochain dans la patrie où
elle remonte son prochain sous la
ceinture
monsieur c'est monstrueux ce sont les
privilèges du progrès et cela crée une
lettre aux chefs d'état monsieur le
président d'une république la source
d'où le cri avance en temps il n'y aura
plus sur terre de quoi nourrir espèce
humaine l'océan se dépeuple les boissons
perry quitte le cheptel savait lui
espère l'homme est omnivore sa chère
donc intensément plus riche en protéines
ces joyaux de la nutrition souligné les
joyaux de la nutrition
l'être humain monsieur le président à
poids égal et le plus charnue de tous
les mammifères et par voie de
conséquence le plus élevé le brillant
s'investit comestibles
car le temps sont assez jambon le mouton
à des gigots comme l'homme à ses cuisses
mais de surcroît l'homme que steve seces
j'écris cela vous voyez un autre mot un
nom de bain calculons le rendement moyen
sur jeunes et 30% à bas coûts easy
nabeul 20% garder le sujet de 8 à 18 ans
sur soi hors catégorie pour
l'exportation et les spas morceaux pour
les pays sous-développés conclure
hamilton l'auteur de fraîches pas les
statistiques établies par ton de paix
mais en temps de guerre sue decker aux
pelotes de mutins bagarre alors j'ai le
président thèque stars et les guerres
révolutions circulation opérations
deviennent ou richert la famille j'ai
raison s est toujours monsieur avec ses
roches et de boue
c'est des choses qui ne s'écrit pas le
cul dans un photo vous rendez pas sa
soute un projet des affichettes aux
couleurs éclatantes t'aime maman joyeuse
prépare en tartine est à bon bain et pas
nui une légende sur la têt du chat petit
avec ces trois mots maman yanam kanté
soler 102 le disque à passer dans les
prises vite et le supermarché thème
solveig
j'ai du bec madère dans mon frigidaire
c'est une courbe et vous mangerez
français de quoi faire revenir à
l'hexagone de ménagère gouffre et les
poussettes d'abord prévoir un dégât
phone dans toutes les rames de métro
annonçant la prochaine
ici pigalle bex régal
place des faits des miettes par quai des
belges où ça crépite me fout une bulle
du pardon des crimes et et qui laisse
une grillade et bat lui obtenir sa
bénédiction pour assurer les curés
abattre et la trinité distribution
gratuite dans tous les séminaires du but
à bex je suis celui tier 2 et d'aix et
2,3 à cela le faisait dans les droits de
les trahir sauver les droits de l'homme
je suggère des treize articles l'état
disposera de tous les restes mortels des
français décédés sans distinction d'âge
ou de sexe
matic 2
[Applaudissements]
dames
mesdames messieurs la pièce qui nous
avons eu l'honneur de jouer devant vous
et de jacques de bâle
les décors de roger à
les costumes de donald kober
avec mon nom des terres
noëlle buso
rené clairement
cyrielle bédard
[Applaudissements]
robert lambert
alamo tech
jacqueline j'aime
dans une mise en scène de jean le
poulain
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]